i need money to start a website
i get this question so often from people
thinking they need
money to get started with their business
and they refuse to do anything
until the money comes in i got a great
question from one of my
youtube readers love you guys youtube
viewers i guess maestro
wrote in i want to start a website i
need more people like web designers
probably some engineers to help me build
the website i think it's a good idea but
i have no money
should i send emails to some venture
capitalist to give me money like startup
money or whatever
so i can pay these people and do what i
do
because i'm not really into this
business so i don't really understand
the last part but
venture capitalists just don't give
money okay nobody's just going to give
you money it doesn't happen that way you
have to have something worth
investing in right you're going to waste
your time pounding your head against the
door
trying to get these venture capitalists
to even see you right
you need to have a lot better worked out
concept here
if you want people to come on board
and to invest in you you have to really
first be clear
what the heck it is that you're doing
right so maestro wrote this this long
comment here
and i don't know what kind of business
he's trying to build
only that he wants to build a website
you've got to create a business for a
reason
what are you trying to accomplish here
make me feel something make me want to
tag on to your movement and feel like
hey
this person is about to take off they're
onto something huge i want to be a part
of it
and then what is it that you bring to
your business
most people who have had successful
websites
if they're starting just a web-based
business they have some kind of
background
in websites so if you're not going to be
the designer the engineer you're not
going to create the site what is it that
you bring to the table
it's really hard to invest in a company
a technology company
when there's no technology in the
business
right so you have a couple options first
is partner with somebody
find somebody that engineer that coder
who believes in what you're doing
who wants to be a part of something
right most people have
boring jobs they hate what they do for a
living
they wake up 90 of america goes to a job
that they hate and come back waiting for
the weekend to start
people are yearning for something to
believe in give them that cause
find the programmer who believes in what
you're doing who wants to do the same
thing
and can join you in this mission okay
that's your first option the second is
just get
started don't wait for your website
don't wait for money to come in
go and get started use facebook
start on facebook that can be your
website that can be your rallying cry
that can be where you put
all your content all your ideas all your
dreams and people
who have the same mind who agree with
what you're saying
can join the cause
don't let lack of money hold you back
from starting this thing up and and i
know that it's really hard and that you
that you think about this isn't possible
without money
right so it's a limiting belief that you
need money to make this thing happen
but it's not the case if you look at the
most successful entrepreneurs in the
world most of them started with nothing
no resources no money just a ton
of effort and a love for what they're
doing and they poured it into their
company and
if you look at the most funded
businesses who started up with tons of
funding they rarely become successful
it's never about the money it's about
how resourceful you can be it's not the
resources
it's the resourcefulness and so get
started find a way to get started today
do something right now to start building
momentum
start a page on facebook start a twitter
account start a youtube channel
something something to get this business
started and even though it's not
the big picture okay it's not the
website that you envisioned
you're making progress towards it
because if the idea is just sitting in
your head
and you never do anything about it it's
just going to die with you
and i don't want that for you i want you
to see this thing happen
so you're dreaming big you've got this
big plan for what you want to have
happen with your company but you got to
start small
and not wait on anything don't wait on
anybody else don't wait on money to come
in don't wait on
the media to find you don't wait on
anything there's nothing holding you
back
start something today and then tomorrow
do something else and the next day do
something else
no matter how small just to make sure
that momentum is happening
for your business if you do that every
day
you'll be shocked at how far you've come
and you'll start attracting the right
people to your company to help you
scale this thing to eventually become
the business that you want it to be
believe for those of you watching you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below i love seeing those come in and
please leave a comment underneath they
really make my day
every time i see them i'd love to hear
from you have a question leave it below
thank you so much and i'll see you soon